and create offense shorthanded four different
stars have scored short-handed goals delandria
right to the front and that was shot wide by
Sam steel along the wall Matt du Shane takes
away been a great addition for Dallas this year
signed in the off season are has 14 goals and
26 assists W Johns sh and dos comes up huge you
know unfortunately like he's just playing with
St so you'd like to see him maybe come back
to front of the net but you know it's it's a
tough read that quick there for him now Dallas
power play they're first of the night they're
11th in the league at 23% on the season gets to
the slot score Joe pavelski who at 39 years old
keeps on filling it up he has his 40th point of
the Year good Puck movement here by Dallas they
get it low One Touch pass right to pelski look
at that release oh one nothing D top shelf over
the right shoulder but somebody's got to get to
him that's that's that's the most dangerous man
Marino does to his defense he does a great job
blocking the initial pass being really honest
but Curtis is outstand we we love the way he
plays the game but I that's that's great for
SARS to say Roberts into the front johnon takes
two a at it and dos keeps it out well Bill you
talk about the line changes and I think it's
key for rough to make sure he's rotating and
using everybody you know second item back to back
big drive from Miller nearly created a rebound
chance for Lazar go ahead South Devil's missing
douy Hamilton as we know and they're missing
Miro H getting one of the best defenseman
in the game here's a fe to oh what see by
Wedgewood and the rebounds kept [Applause] out
Scott Wedgewood full extension keeps the Stars
ahead well Devil's come close to tying this
hockey game up good cross siiz pass drive to
the net Mercer gets it to Meyer it gets up over
the pad one more look at it right through the legs
Mercer makes that pass past hack andpa and Meer
redirects it gets it to the floor forand chips
it sits right in the blue paint and really good
job this is what the Dallas team is about what he
was throughout his career and he was a rookie guy
here's Curtis Lazar fan out in the slot back hand
to the doorstep oh my Wedgewood got over again
that time on holla foot going to work behind that
I think he's just picked up his second penalty of
the day Puck comes toward the front a good chance
goes off the side neck Craig Smith wraps around
doesn't go and the whistle blows top unit of
kir brat to fully Meer and Hughes out Jasper brat
works hard down the wall Center for h p bouncing
oh it's knocked away as brat tried to jam it in
we've seen that a few times here tonight whether
they five on five the power play where just out
of the reach of a devil around the crease or
that Pucks in the back of the net it just it's
coming close I think hackin paa got a piece of
it to knock it away here's tley pulls it back
toley shoot save Wedgewood what a move by tley
luk Hughes gains The Zone he is pickpocketed look
out R rope hints to the offensive end looking for
a shorty and dos makes the save sa rope hint can
fly and Luke Hughes was out there a while he did
a pretty good job of at least you know catching
up there but he's got to be careful at the end of
a a shift on the power play you you can't hang on
too much cuts it back and he scores short handed
a Nifty move around nemit and he pops it into the
corner with the backand two nothing Dallas Devil's
power play looked pretty effective just couldn't
bu but the young defenseman Nemitz gets beat here
to the inside and rope hint has done this to a lot
of D but he puts it between the stick and skates
when you get your feet turned and angled against
speed and a guy with great hands like hin that's
when you get in trouble and look at him go back
backand against the graen and it's a two nothing
lead for the Stars he touching that b you got to
be careful but I mean that's a great oh my oh what
a response and it didn't go for Marino unbel
unable again on to start working on removing
the cour and getting the ice going until about
3:00 this afternoon and they had it ready to go
by about six good hard work by the crew here yeah
they do a terrific job for sure no doubt here's
duchan sliding one across good defense but duain
finds the rebound and sticks it in Miller and
Hughes had eaten up the pass but it bounced right
to the Shan and it's 3 nothing Dallas has just
played a good structured game and and wait for the
Counterattack and you watch here good stick there
by Luke and he blocks the initial shot but again
a little bit one more look right there and then
ends up going off Miller and then the puck goes
right back right back to San and an easy one for
foruan that's that's what we've seen on a couple
goals here Bill where sud finds the loose Puck
rims it all the way around hin retrieves it there
23 seconds to go in the period Wyatt Johnson on
the cycle feeds hint he scor that was a gorgeous
shift from the Dallas Top Line robe hint finishes
it off as Dallas continues to cycle in the devil
Zone look at this pass and nobody's got hins who's
goes right through the middle here and he's too
open way too open there a nice pass by Smith
Puck squirts away to Dawson Mercer three on two he
moves It Wide to Michael McLoud who blasts and it
knocks the mask off of Wedgewood comes up the wall
Craig Smith knocks it along and it it's about fit
right you're going to a veteran team I know he's a
veteran but he's been great talent skills skating
ability but at times Smith snaps it in that's off
the blocker and through Craig Smith makes it five
nothing Smith takes a shot from way out and is a
little bit screened did it go off right between
the legs of nit so I want to see that stick
get out in front and and get on that shot but
Wedgewood tough tough to pick up out with Michael
McLoud who just changed out Devils complete the
line change now as McLoud carries but ell bullies
him off the [Applause] puck Johnston oh Nifty drag
and he scores goodness gracious why at Johnston
with a highlight real goal to make it 6 nothing
we got to show some pride like ryce said here 1242
left but this is a heck of a move you watch right
there Luke Hughes just commits a little too early
and then you get caught good move by by Johnson
and it's unraveled it had in the second period
and and we didn't see that bill we don't see
that an incredible move and we've seen the devil's
D tonight a little frustrated getting beat a few
times in this game for goals and it really feels
like that goal from hin that made it two nothing
short-handed for all intents and purposes that was
the end of the game from then on Dallas completely
rolled Devils got frustrated more mistakes scw
and that's why we're sitting here 6 nothing here's
Brett he scores so the Devils finally get one pass
to Wedgewood and it's a 6-1 game fire to brat but
they get it up ice that's the pass up the middle
little drop from heer and finds BR all alone and
he slides it underneath Scott wagwood to put the
Devils at least on the board here's a question
for you someone who played for L Amarillo for a
long time does the Shaving rule apply to coaches
too is uh Patrick La going to have to shave the
beard that he had coaching Colorado you know what
those kind of to fall he it in and hopefully this
will be the one that breaks the seal for Tyler to
fulley 62 every little thing and hopefully that
Sparks him right as he fakes it does a good job
of drawing the defender down and blast it past the
glove of Wedgewood so you know that's good to he
needed that yep it's his first goal it is moved
Along by Scott Wedgewood Dallas scores the six
first goals in this game the devil's close with
the final two but it's a 6-2 victory for the Stars